[Musica]
[Applauso]
ecco è esattamente quelli che vedeva
vedeva preoccupate di mariti per prezzi
altri invece ma cosa sta dicendo creta
pochi invece quelli che hanno compreso
perché qui in sala ci sono persone sorde
e udenti che conoscono anche tagli ma
dei segni ma tutti i libri che tipo di
sensazioni avete provato di voto ma
rimento ignoto perplessità anche di
curiosità perché no queste cielo le
tette emozioni e sensazioni che provano
le persone sorde quando si trovano di
fronte a qualcosa che non è
comprensibile di pronta qualcosa che non
è accessibile queste quelle coprivamo
noi ogni giorno in un mondo ha creato
super per le persone prudenti
però sicuramente sorrido perché vi
chiederete a ma quindi una persona sorda
parla e provare a farlo prima no il mio
obiettivo è fatta sera e di provare a
rispondere a tutte le domande che
avreste sempre voluto fare ad una
persona sorda come quelli che cantante
icona striscia le dieci domande che
avreste sempre voluto fare a domande
spesse volte a volte insolite o comode
ma domanda è sempre e comunque molto
importanti domanda alle quali ha sempre
risposto nel corso della mia vita
in tutti questi 28 anni provando ad
abbattere tutti quei pregiudizi
stereotipi che da semplici sono intorno
al mondo dalla sordità ad oggi a madonna
pagana incinta vengono proposti naceri
di test genetici molto meno rispetto a
una mia scelta di onav innocenti tra le
malattie genetiche più frequenti
infettate sul sangue materno
ci sono e stragi le beta talassemia
distrofia muscolare fibrosi cistica e la
sordità congenita
malattia perciò è qui che sta il
problema di tonno la sordità non è una
malattia
proviamo noi addetti miracolo altri
termini la sordità limite la sordità è
una mancanza cioè noi due parole
oggettive che possono essere dati in
contesti diversi come per noi nascere il
mondo di silenzio la musica come nacque
come cento nella media alle persone
sorde mistero ecco che mischa cote
viaggio insieme
vorrei portarvi con me nel mio mondo
fatta anche di silenzio provando ad
abbattere tutti quei pregiudizi
stereotipi provando a condividere con
voi che cosa significa essere persone
sorde al giorno d'oggi vi incuriosirà
incuriosirà sapere che cosa vuol dire
essere sordi profondi adesso però vivere
quella che ho detta amish
mi chiamo ilaria 28 anni abita a bergamo
c'è una sorda profonda dalla nascita per
un fattore ereditario
mi mancano le cellule gigliata interno
dalla coppia che funzionano da recettori
sensoriali
sono cioè quelle cellule responsabili
della tramissione acustica delle
informazioni al tema nervoso centrale
quindi che cosa vuol dire essere sordi
profondi nel mio caso avere una perdita
di tivat che va oltre i 95 decibel che
cosa vuol dire
vuoi dire non sentire fino ad un rumore
pari a
capital ha sentito anche io in viciniori
vuol dire non sentire la beata marshall
dove avrete capito ci sono diversi tipi
e diversi gradi di sordità a seconda
dalla perdita uditiva che ben misurata
invece ben la cia di tappa è certa la
nascita oppure en charger e api tardi
per diversi il da realtek auge la base
ordita all'anno coperta sette mesi
eravamo in montagna in un paesino
chiamato ponte giurino dalle parti di
berbenno provincia di bergamo era una
domenica difetta eravamo nel sagrato
della chiesa ed erano suonate
all'improvviso e le campane
tutti ma proprio tutti si erano
spaventati tranne ovviamente io e forse
per questo motivo che mi chiedo spesso
chi è che ci dice il a ma sempre apre
shore da come una campana a nove mesi
sono stata per te citata ed ha iniziato
un lungo percorso di terapia e di
logopedia oggi in italia nascono più di
mille bambini sordi ogni anno e con
crimini e meno natalie cole diagnosi
percorsi
molti di questi bambini intraprendono da
subito un percorso di riabilitazione
alla parola e alla q8
grazie anche all'uso di protti di acqui
impianti cocleari recentemente era
uscita una foto sui social che è
diventata virale di dolcissimo papa che
chi era tatuate l'impianto cocleare per
far sentire meno sola la sua famiglia la
sua fida la tecnologia da pete punto di
vista sta facendo e dai progressi enormi
mi preme però precisa harvick che ogni
famiglia fa le sue scelte molto
personali
in merito ai percorsi educativi e
riabilitativi tante a prendere per i
propri figli quello che condivido io con
voi è quello che si tratta di me
dall'ana sperienza e della mia
e c'è la crescita bilingue da mamma
udente pa password mamma e figlia di
genitori sordi papà e figlio di genitori
utenti
il fratello di mia madre è udente la
sorella di ma papà assurda io ho un
fratello di quattro anni più grande
evidente o cugini sordi cugini denti
somma un gran casino
se una crescita quindi con la lingua dei
segni italiana ecco l'italia hanno
parlato due lingue completamente diverse
ho imparato a parlare grazie alla lingua
dei segni
ogni segno corrispondeva a una parolina
per esempio il segno palla diventava il
concetto palla poi diventava la parola
palla i segni e le paroline merci
insieme inventavano perdere tra gi
intere
faccio un esempio ilaria questi mesi è
il mio nome vai a prendere la palla ora
sicuramente la domanda che sorge
spontanea è ma come può un bambino
capire la differenza tra una vocale è
una consonante i sordi anche delle
ottime capacità visive quando è meno
mancare un senso tiene il pano medio
altri tra cui la vista e quindi la
lettura labiale le lettere dell'alfabeto
possono essere insegnata anche
attraverso e tatto la mamma di mamma per
me era la mia mammina appoggiata sulla
guancia di mamma e papà che vive a farlo
è più facile a farsi che a dirsi la l è
la vigeva mente facile e si vede la
lingua poggiata sul palato la s e la
gita queste sconosciute difficile da
vedersi da pronunciarci ed acquetarci se
ne va sempre state il crash dalla mele
dop e ditta anni tante le dimentico da
qualche parte la r la era una bellissima
storia ma mamma quando mi portava dava
luca pd sta a fare terapia
pare coinvolgeva sempre il mio fratello
e roberto che con tanta pazienza con
tanto amore è stato una parte importante
del mio percorso di crescita ci
mettevano sul pianoforte affinché
sentissi le vibrazioni subito accorpa i
suoni la musica i rumori dei ne vanno se
nati sotto forma di gioco toccare per
mano e l'arpa e capire che faceva il
rumore diverso rispetto a tamburello
rispetto al pianoforte e questa
macchinina questa macchina che il mio
fratello faceva passare sul tutto il
corpo sulle braccia sul collo sulla
schiena 7 palme dai piedi facendo il mio
libero e che gitante perisce letti co è
stata così importante importante perché
e dài e dài e dài è arrivata questa
fatidica rpg da ho detto è diventata
roberto ciappi tempi da qualche parte
non ti vedo grazie roberto
[Applauso]
in tutte le disposizioni legislative
vigenti
il termine il sordomuto è stato
sostituito dalla parola sordo grazie
alla legge dal 20 febbraio del 2006 per
te le persone sorda nelle corde vocali
integre e possono cioè uno in grado di
parlare che tolgono scelga la lingua dei
segni o di parlare o entrambe le lingue
una scelta libera autonoma e come tale
va rispettata vecchio chi non mi conosce
quando mi sente parlare per la prima
volta mi cambia per una straniera ma non
so tempi un po francese spagnola però
cablo shaila scienza di bergamo
signori non chiedetemi come faccio a
dove la gente di bergamo non me lo so
spiegare neanche io la cernita quindi la
disabilità nasce dal momento in cui ci
si mette in relazione con una persona
sorda vitara mai capitato di incontrare
persone sorde e di non sapere magari
come relazionarvi tendendo di indagare a
disagio succede non ci lascia e affetto
e bando imparati ci si impara dalle
esperienze l'era scena qui ha scitto
quando dico poi che siano una persona
sorda mi dispiace che poi ti dispiace di
corda scusami non aveva capito adesso
provo a parlare più piano rendendomi la
conversazione ancora più difficile
diversi iniziano a urlare a volte la
sordità sembrano in egitto ahahah bella
bisognava il proprio sentire a la
sordità volta ricci a volte invece
sembra essere un luogo
fammi indovinare che percario francese
no guarda sono una persona sorda a
interessante e dove si trova
quindi come ci si relazionerà con una
persona scelta semplice metterci davanti
all'interlocutore parlare normalmente
scandire le parole se necessario
assicurarsi che abbia capito anche c'è
la soluzione migliore a volte a chiedere
alla stessa persona cosa vuole come
preferisce quelle di ci parli le tette
atti di retata preferisce da un anno e
mezzo vive a bergamo e un appartamento
in affitto e specie la domanda che mi
viene rivolta alla seguente ma come fa
il dell'arte mattino ci sono quelli
positivi luminosi che producono anche
vibrazioni yoko et al vega che grande
piumino così roberto il mio fratello sta
bene di cosa sto parlando
questa ebbe da gioco al bayda che metto
sotto cuscino
ha ragione mia mamma a volta dirmi
quando ero un po anche un panel più
piccola tu sei sciorba solo quando vuoi
azzardiamo a parlare dall'arrivo dei
segni come tutte le lingue parlate la
lingua dei segni è una lingua che con
temi ed aspetti verbali ed effetti non
verbali ha una sua grammatica è una sua
sintassi bene è un canale che tollera
una comunicazione che sfrutta il canale
di gb gestuale il messaggio è ben
espressa attraverso un messaggio
attraverso i movimenti del corpo
le espressioni del viso e le mani di
guardo versale no la lingua decenni è
varia da paese a paese ci arriva di sim
italiana lingua decine americane un
guado insieme inglese ecco in libia
oggi l'italia non è di pochi e ultimi
paesi a livello europeo a non vedersi
riconosciuta questa lingua
la convenzione dall'onu dal 2006 sui
diritti delle persone con disabilità
riconosce ufficialmente le lingue dei
segni promuovendone el acquisizione il
mancato riconoscimento da parte
dell'italia beer conoscere l'anima è una
grave inadempienza all'avvenuta
ratificata da na
la convenzione non solo il
riconoscimento dalla dis garantirebbe ad
una persona la piena libertà di
scegliere come comunicare e di avere un
effettivo accesso limitato all
informazione educazione istruzione
servizi sociali lavorativi ricreativi e
quell idea non solo per tutte quelle
persone che non conoscono la lingua dei
segni
perché effettivamente ci sono anche
persone che non la conoscono in
particolare fidi share di di genitori
intenti che portano le protesi e di
tanti tanti cocleari aggiunge aggiungono
i mancati servizi adeguati
la mancata accessibilità nei diversi
ambiti della vita quotidiana quale
università passioni aeroporti ospedali
uffici ascensori cade dal tra dal i
teatri cinema fiore per citarne alcuni
i sottotitoli in televisione solo su
pochi canali e specie velo interi solo
in prima serata
per non parlare delle dirette dai
telegiornali
mi fermo qui che ahmed tra tutte le
domande per concludere questo viaggio
insieme tra tutte le domande che mi sono
state fatte infetti 28 anni ce n'è una
che ma particolarmente colpito è stata
fatta da un bambino di 9 anni era un
poeta cola a parlare della mia
esperienza
la domanda che mi è rivolta la seguente
ma se inventassero una pillola che li
minacce per sempre la tua share dita e
di darci la possibilità di diventare
utente e quindi di sentire la
prenderesti sì o no la metterà subito la
gt vicende di ma che domande fi
no signori è stata una domanda
bellissima bellissima perché mi ha messo
nelle condizioni di poter riflettere
telo tornata indietro nel tempo si sono
aperti tutti questi flash flash back
come nel film
mi rivedevo io dap che l'ha seguita su
queste pianoforte con queste prote dico
di grandi che mi facevano la racchia
dentro imparare al tar e al mondo
accennare un futuro facile per noi a
chiedermi che cosa avrei fatto da grande
c'è il ce l'avrei fatta con tutti i
sacrifici tate per harvard in cui i
pianti i dolori dei baby giani le primi
traguardi
il sentirsi diversa le frustazioni le
sofferenze le conquiste e di come stata
una grande conquista essere qui
sul palco e di te e bergamo 2000 19
davanti a voi immaginate il quale
saltata la mia risposta
grazie
[Applauso]